[音楽]
どのさあ億円のお家の持ち主ですて付けた
反映どうですかあの家はあの
スロッすごいデカすげった徳展で買った
だけある大きさの家なんですけども
正直っていうか正直ね
日かすぎる間違いないで扱い結構引っ越し
する講座間違いですきっと引越ししてきて
思ったのは意外とデカイと聞いちゃダメだ
なというか言って大きいすぎてもダメです
小さすぎてもダメなんかなースってそこで
今回なんとですねサーん系のうちの
風鈴など村内の来てもの見つけました
タイトル見たらわかると思うけどもなんと
幅がう
3m の家がありました yeah
すごいない人二人ファイル&ね礼に俺で
混ぜいやでもこれがそれなんですけども
パスと見て僕は横から見ると分からない
でしょウンターってもいいですけど家の幅
が3メートルということであっちから見て
みましょうかきますよ皆さん
これですよこれ
コフレっ
あっはい
すごいないん
やばいよすごくなんか3m って
ブーブー家で満足してるんですけども
キャンペーンの打つと3m の家と比べて
みたいなぁと思って言っうわぁちょっと
内見会
にょにとっていますからこのさ確か
自身ちょっと民泊あああああこれ
食い
だけでさっそく入っていきましょうか
まずすごいなーさん
車がサイルっていうんだってと取ること
ないから今度は自転車すごいの分科会とさ
れるなってくんじゃあさっそく幅3
メートルのうちいっていきたいとおもい
ます
いや元あるよある
お願いしまーす
イントって
いが入った広い入った感じ別に何か窮屈感
なんでもないですよあっ
おしゃれされ抑えて不正かかっているはず
であることが玄関ということ言って
ただいまなきゃいけないでしょお答え0
てい前提なんだしを言っています
広い一枚が
を生やしたりしたいいらっしゃいませんお
邪魔します大
全然アイデアブックカード
3m ってさもっとさせまいと思ったけど
そんなことないさ意外と広いですね
ただこれは1回ってこと91階です
ザッハ支援班も入れに来られたのである
まず言うと思う
バカなしている
たださ
全然広い全然広い
でこれですんはぁっ
とワンちゃんここに喪服を着ているくらい
ですて a 直下3m なるそんなもんか
弊社の車両とさよこ暗い話リスナやって
いうと意外と3m 1ようになって思った
ん
レイドコンパクトでかわいい this
age ねぇー便利あげる
回ダウンすごいやっぱさ3メートルだから
詰め込んでるからチェコ九尾になってる
やつ鈴鹿へ上がってみますそう
おおすごいなぁ
これまで何回だけかも知らずに生きていく
んだけど
おここが2回出て至極な色いっすよね立っ
てみて
[音楽]
ブーブー
言っ我こそ year
8いろいろあのいえどスーツ下取り強さの
共存でないから不ヤバすぎるます以上十分
際にマジで十分です
エットってなんで
ストーン家の冷蔵庫が勝手に開けちゃダメ
だかねぇ
けい豚っなれば彼はけどなんか嫌だから
livin がちょっとキュッてなっ
ちゃって
でも公園でさぁ
お酒とかも見たかってみるそうですね
隣に女おいてね
おおおおおお
いいでしょ付いてるそう結果旅行はさあ
3m だけど縦に長いからジュークさが
半分くらいで時間は
フリーでとか
黒子バカな安保黒ばですねー
[音楽]
いいいいねあってもいい気いる
私は席をつけます
でも持っ
小さいというのはああそろそろ
サティいいの月ないよくっだっており
ずいぶん3メートル幅どぅっ
全然キュッ
ファー帽
デーっ
てこれがん稼いだしとかおトクになります
いや全然広いけどこれをパストイレだ
ああああっ全然普通にあるうーん
今のところ普通の家紹介だよ大丈夫
いやいや入れイヤホン大奈路想定して打っ
たんですけど
上野さすがに寝すぎ2冊蹴り線あいっしょ
革ジャンってめっちゃ変わりで階段から
容赦礼をされまして
いきます
me
おおぉ
性質ですかいや広いぞマジ広い必要が広い
され安保でブワーです
はてビアでございますこちらは2人でも影
が押され壁を車列がやって利用の進出も
余裕で準備できると
いやめちゃめちゃ広いや強いおっすごいと
末で
俺んちの庭筆くれんかな要相談まであり
ましょう相談ですさらに後3回なんですか
もうもう一個エロスとバーみたいなので
すごいっていいでしょこれが最後の回です
ね
すぎだぞ
かわいくねーロフト子供部屋にしちゃっ
てるみたいねああ
レベラーの秘密基地みたいなね最高数年た
してねそれとかさん
確かに可愛げがあってねっ
止めあっこういう部分が
pred された自分
ここがいろいろ収納できた分はん
ここにケースを教えるとううわああ座さあ
こちら女の子みたいなかったがですわー
[拍手]
すごいなぁ
これは何がすごいかって言うカバーさ横幅
がない分
て幅と高さですごい大きく見えるから前何
かいても苦しくないんだよね都会とかさ
ちょっと待ちな場所ってさせ前田ウィン
リィとか狭い場所とかそういうところに
行ったてやすいっていうのが売りだし
なるほどこれで入ってみると意外とこう
やっていい感じで生活できるって言うのを
この後出るハウスではかさ学びますもっと
狭くてたんですか
まじかみたいなうわぁこれ
せばいいよ痛いとかそうおっしゃる悔しい
わけだ
いらっしゃい思いますね素敵な
可能な意見照会やキーということがあるん
ですけど
おいくらぐらいます建物は10坪の3階
だけで30坪何歳でちょっと消えてモデル
ハウス仕様にしてしまったのでうん
400万円と消費税で建築しています
なるほど
いきますでもなんかさぁ件のうちも結構気
がたら白いんですけど
受けませこういう温泉あの僕ザーッと昨日
の夜 google で調べさせて
いただいたんですけども
すごい家がこれボク日ですねあの今
google のあのストリートビューで
長さがあの測れる測定できるものですから
始め社長の土地調べたら今日は短19m
かけるこちらの長さが33m
ね3 meter の絵を入れてみたら3
メイサかける11m この人は口がこの
うちってことですねそうなんでもう13個
並びました敷地は73戸はい13かける
さんで
39戸39戸
395度039金で動くよね話せ合わせれ
ばまたかた後小さくなりますけどもう吠え
に後か日本的で作れるというあ十分作れ
ますバーンでここに
フィットいきましょう入ってございます
みたいなせ
あっ
[音楽]
はあっ
は国公とこの辺に巻いてるんでちと何個か
食べらにすべて俺